Opel's latest creation is the Crossland X
- a subcompact crossover.
Part SUV, part minivan, it aims to combine
the best of both worlds - in other words,
generous space inside with a fresh, cutting-edge
look.
And the Crossland X certainly succeeds in
that.
Car tester Emmanuel Schäfer mentions that
the strongest growth is in the B-segment,
or small cars.
Their sales figures have doubled in the last
four years.
So carmakers are scrambling to roll out new
B-segment models.
Opel's contribution is the Crossland X.
It resembles its somewhat bigger brother,
the Mokka X, but tones down the sportiness
and aggressive looks in favor of greater practicality
in everyday driving.
We test-drove the largest available engine,
the 1.2 liter turbo-gasolin with 96 kilowatts.
It heaves the Crossland X from zero to 100
kilometers per hour in 9.1 seconds, with a
top speed of 206 kilometers per hour.
Emmanuel explains that, when a carmaker introduces
a new model in a segment, they want it to
stand out from its competitors.
Opel achieves this with driver assists - such
as Pedestrian Detection, which the Crossland X
is the first in its segment to offer.
The front reveals the connection between the
Mokka and the Crossland: Opel's logo is mounted
on the grille, flanked by chrome winglets.
The embedded, low-mounted fog lights emphasize
its SUV credentials.
The visible underbody protection should do
away with any worries about scratched paint.
Depending on the trim level, the colours of
the side mirrors and roof contrast
with the rest of the body.
The gently sloping roof contour recalls a
minivan.
LED tail lights are only offered with the
highest trim level, the 'Selection', as it's called.
Folding down the rear seats expands the trunk
volume from 410 to 1255 liters.
The interior gives a neat impression.
Many of the switches are set on the steering
wheel.
The eight-inch Touch-Infotainment system adds
at least 650 euros to the price, regardless
of the trim level.
Air conditioning is standard, but automatic
climate control only comes with the Selection line.
Opel is rolling out the Crossland X with a
range of five engines,
starting with the 1.2 liter gasoline engine with 60 kilowatts.
The most powerful, though still quite fuel-efficient,
is a 1.2-liter turbo gasoline engine
with 96 kilowatts.
Emmanuel describes the Crossland X's suspension
as offering both comfort and sportiness - though
a bit more comfort than sportiness.
He forgives its slight tendency to roll - the
body sits a little higher than normal - saying
it's no problem, and the car takes curves
nimbly and swiftly.
The Crossland X replaces the Mokka X as the
entry-level model for Opel's X range.
The biggest model, the Grandland X, is on
its way.
It will round off the X range at the top.
Prices for the Crossland X start at just under
17,000 euros in Germany.
But the 1.2 turbo edition we tested
will set you back at least 21,000 euros.